rifles army fatigues
and conflict but this isn't the us
military in louisville
it's a far-right group known as the oath
keepers
who claim they were invited here by
business owners
[Music]
they insist they're here to protect not
provoke
what does the presence of your gun do i
mean clearly people are aggravated
uh well it's for self-protection it was
one thing but
we've made a promise to people not to
let the buildings be burnt down and we
won't
i'm just walking you're what
you take your friends
and they claim it's all about keeping
the peace
but there's no tranquility on show here
it didn't feel very peaceful no punches
thrown no shots fired
it's freedom of speech they have that
right just like we do we believe in
their peaceful protesting
they have their right to protest just
like we do
but some have to fight hard to resist
the urge to react
brianna taylor is their focus
these men have a very different agenda
so what is it that you think this is
going to do
uh deter arson like we did in ferguson
we were the guys on the rooftops in
ferguson protected both businesses
and apartments in fact we're here also
protecting residents we don't want to
say who they are
or they live because they're afraid
they're afraid of retaliation so we're
protecting life and property
as night fell the protesters pursued
their fight
against police brutality and systemic
racism they've been doing this for more
than a hundred days and they say they're
determined to keep doing it
until they see a change and so this
nightly ritual
continues a constant game of cat and
mouse with police
this is where briana taylor was killed
deja moore lived opposite the gun shells
was like
all around my door frame she firmly
believes the police
should have been charged with killing
her yeah
where does louville where does america
go from here
honestly a change needs to come now
whether they like it or not
it's gonna turn violent we're upset
we're angry we're disappointed
and if they don't change it then we will
it's hard to see an end to the anger
here without some radical change
cordelia lynch sky news louisville
kentucky